hey there jobseekers welcome back this
is episode 19 of Udacity career tips my
name is Martin McGovern ER today we are
discussing what makes a great LinkedIn
profile
if you saw our previous video you
understand that having a LinkedIn
profile is incredibly important to your
job search but what we didn't have time
to go into is exactly how do you make
your profile quote-unquote great let's
get into it
when it comes to your LinkedIn profile
the main thing you have to do is have
one if you don't have a LinkedIn profile
that is a huge red flag to hiring
managers recruiters and like even if
your profile is empty it is better to
have an empty LinkedIn profile than no
LinkedIn profile at all of course of
course the goal is to get to an all-star
status profile but let's not worry about
that today we need to walk before we can
run I don't expect you to go from 0 to
60 in six seconds if you're watching
this video right now and you don't have
a LinkedIn profile it means you're on
YouTube and you need to pause this video
immediately and go create your profile
I'll wait are you still here did you go
create your profile and come back
awesome that means you have a LinkedIn
profile and we can get into the details
how to take it from good to great here
are the seven things you have to do
right now number one the profile pic
make it professional also do not wear
red red means stop don't hire me try
something like blue or a neutral color
number two the background cover image go
to pixels com it's a free site to
download free stock photos pick
something simple or generic it could be
the sky a cityscape or just a geometric
pattern it'll all work upload it and
you're good to go
number three your headline put in the
job title that you have if you're
currently employed or the one you wish
you had if you're in between jobs right
now don't say you're looking for a job
or opened opportunities or currently
seeking these will not come up in the
search results when recruiters and
hiring managers are searching for
potential candidates number four your
summary try to talk about the impact you
want to have on the world if you don't
know the impact that you want to have in
the world talk about how you help people
if you don't know how you help people
talk about the job you wish you had and
list your relevant skills it's a good
enough place to start number five your
experience list every job you've ever
had that is relevant to your career I go
all the way back to my first video agra
fir job in highschool because that was
the first time i ever created videos but
i don't talk about my caddying
experience if it's old or irrelevant
delete it then for each one of these
jobs make sure that the link is
connected to the company profile so the
logo shows up and lists three bullet
points of what you did while in that
role feel free to start by just pulling
those bullets straight from your resume
it's good enough to start number six
your education this one's pretty
self-explanatory fill it out don't
stress out too much about it just
include all the classes certifications
and things that are relevant to your
career and number seven your skills this
is interestingly the most important part
of your profile because having all of
your skills listed will rank you higher
in the SEO and have you show up in the
search results when recruiters and
hiring managers are looking for talent a
lot of people didn't know that they
could add their own skills in this
section so go ahead and do that right
now
and let's just stop there do these seven
things and your profile will be good
enough to get going on the rest of your
search never let an incomplete profile
stop you from networking applying and
going after that job that you want once
you've done these seven things you've
got the basics and you can build the
rest as you go
and for those of you who want to take
things to the next level start sharing
articles and commenting on people's
posts you'll not only show up in their
feed but also the feeds of people they
know this will quickly increase your
visibility on LinkedIn and help you get
noticed we will be digging into each one
of these things in future videos so stay
tuned subscribe on YouTube and follow us
on LinkedIn and keep asking questions
that we can dive into in future videos
thank you so much for watching
tag a friend who you know is searching
for a job right now and I wish you the
best of luck in your search see you soon